you've done a study on
cocaine and sexual decision making
uh can you explain
can you explain the findings i mean uh
in a broad
sense how do you do a study
that involves cocaine and
uh the other how do you do a study
involving this
sexual decision making and then
how do you do a study that combines both
yeah sex and drugs too i'm just missing
the rock and roll
it's not too controversial rock and roll
isn't very controversial anymore
yeah so the cocaine you know lots of
hoops to jump through you got to have a
lot of medical
support you got to be at a basically an
institution a research
unit like i'm at that has a long history
and the ability to
to do that and
get ethics approval get fda approval but
it's possible and
whenever you're dealing with something
like cocaine you would never want to
give that to a
not someone who hasn't already used
cocaine and you want to make sure you're
not giving it to someone who's an active
user who wants to quit
so the idea is like okay if you're if
you're using this type of drug anyway
and you're we're really sure you're not
looking to quit
hey use use a couple times in the lab
with us so we can at least learn
something um and part of what we learn
is maybe to help people not use and
it'll reduce the harms
of of cocaine so there's hoops to jump
through
with the sexual decision-making i looked
at the main thing i looked at was this
model of
i applied delayed discounting to what we
talked about earlier the now versus
later
that kind of decision-making that goes
along with addiction i applied that to
condom use decisions
um and and i've done probably published
about 20 or so papers with this and
different drugs and
and uh so the the primary metric is
whether you do or don't use a condom
that's the most right
oh hypothetic so this is using
hypothetical decision making but i've
published
some studies looking at um showing a
tight correspondence to
um in correlational studies to
self-reported behavior
so this is like so like how do you did
you do a questionnaire kind of thing
right so it's a it's not quite a
questionnaire but but it's a
it's a it's a behavioral task
requiring them to to respond to so you
show pictures of a bunch of individuals
and it's it's kind of like one of these
fun behavioral like a lot of them you
get like
numbers are born but it's like okay hot
or not like which of these 60 people
would you have a one night stand with
men women so pick whatever you like a
little bit of this a little bit of that
whatever you're into it's all
variety there out of that group you pick
some subsets of people who do you think
is the
you know the one you most want to have
sex with the least he thinks most likely
have an sti or at least likely a
sexually transmitted disease by sti
and then you could do certain decision
making questions so what i've done is
asked
say this percy read a vignette this
person wants to have sex with you now
you've met them to get along
um casual sex scenario like a one-night
stand
with a condom's available just rate your
likelihood from 1-100 on
this kind of scale would you use it but
then you can change your
your scenario to say okay now imagine
you have to wait five minutes to use a
condom
so that the choice is now instead of
using condom versus not in terms of your
likelihood scale
it now it ranges from um have sex now
without a condom
versus on the other end of the scale is
weight five minutes to have sex with a
condom so you rate your likelihood
of where your behavior would be along
that continuum and then you could say
okay well what about an hour
what about three hours what about you
know what about 24 hours
i'm misunderstanding uh
now without a condom or five minutes
later with a condom
right isn't the so what what's supposed
to be the preference
for the person like is like what
there's a lot of factors coming into
play right there's like
like there's like pleasure personal
preference
and then there's also the safety those
are two like
are those competing objectives right and
so we do get at that through some
individual measures and and this task is
more of a face valid task where there's
a lot underneath the hood
so for most people sex with the condom
is the better reward
but underneath the hood of that is just
that the purely physical level they'd
rather have sex
with without the condom it's going to
feel bad what do you mean by reward like
when they calculate their trajectory
through life
and try to optimize it then sex with the
condom is a good idea
well it's it's it's it's really based on
i mean yeah
yeah presumably that's the case that
that that there's
but it's measured by like what would
really that first question where there
is no delay
most people say they would be at the
higher net scale a lot of times 100
percent they
said they would definitely use use
economy a condom not everybody
and that we know that's the case see
it's like that that some people don't
like com some people
say yeah i i want to use a condom but
you know a quarter of the time ended up
not because i guess getting lost in the
passion of the moment
so for the people i mean the only reason
that people
so behaviorally speaking at least for a
large number of people in many
circumstances condom use is a reinforcer
just because people do it
like you know why are they doing it
they're
not because it makes the sex feel better
but because
it makes that it allows for at least the
same
general reward even if actually even if
it feels a little bit not as good
yeah you know with the condom
nonetheless they get most of the benefit
without the concurrent oh my gosh
there's this risk of either unwanted
pregnancy or getting hiv
or way more likely than hiv you know
herpes
you know in general awards etc all the
all the lovely ones
um and we've actually done research
saying like where we
gauge the probability of these
individual s different sdi's and it's
like what's the heavy hitter in terms of
what people are using to judge you know
to evaluate they're going to use a
condom
so that's why the condom use is the
delayed thing five minutes or more
and then uh that yeah because this would
normally be the larger later reward like
the ten dollars versus the nine it's
like the ten dollar which is
counterintuitive if you just think about
the physical pleasure so that's a good
that's a good thing to measure so condom
use is a really good concrete quantity
quantitative quantifiable thing that you
can use in a study and then you can add
a lot of different elements
like the presence of cocaine and so on
yeah you can get people loaded on
like any number of drugs like cocaine
alcohol and methamphetamine are the
three that i've done and published on
and it's interesting that these are fun
studies
man right i love to get people loaded in
in a safe context and like but to really
it started like there was some early
research alcohol i mean the psychedelics
are the most interesting but it's like
all of these drugs are fascinating the
fact that all these are keys that
unlock a certain like psychological
experience in
in the head
you